bonsoir merci beaucoup donné cueillir
merci david merci alors on va passer
dans le monde numérique
on va oublier l'usinage d'additifs on va
passer dans le monde numérique avec
imagine with orange
la raison d'être d'un projet numérique
pourquoi on fait le projet c'est souvent
aussi important que ce qu'on fait ce
qu'on va délivrer à la fin le pourquoi
est aussi important que le quoi le
pourquoi la raison d'être c'est ce qui
va vous permettre d'entraîner les gens
avec vous c'est ce qui va vous permettre
de faire de votre idée du rêve du savon
de marseille
une aventure collective et c'est ça la
réussite d'un projet d'innovation
c'est une aventure collective alors le
pourquoi de imagine with orange pour moi
il vient de l'afrique l'afrique c'est un
continent étonnant multiples facettes
mais aussi sur l'innovation numérique
l'innovation numérique et foisonnante
là-bas le pénétration du mobile est
étonnante
on est déjà dans certains pays à près de
80 100 % de pénétration du mobile
on dit que l'internet va arriver sur le
mobile en afrique sans passer par le
réseau fixe comme on l'a connu en france
ou aux états unis
2g 3g 4g les innovations se multiplient
voilà le pourquoi on va prendre un
exemple d'innovation qui vous illustre
la possibilité du mobile en afrique et
l'environnement qui a donné lieu à cette
innovation
les africains sont assez peu bancarisés
notamment au kenya
et pourtant ils doivent transférer se
passer de l'argent quand on travaille à
naïrobi et qu'on doit donner de l'argent
à sa famille qui reste au village
comment on fait eh bien on prend
l'argent liquide
on donne au chauffeur du bus qui fait le
trajet jusqu'au village
la famille vient à l'arrêt du bus
chercher l'argent et rentrer au village
à pied c'est vrai l'argent se perd
l'argent évolue
comment on peut faire quand on n'a pas
de comptes bancaires pour améliorer ça
et bien on a un mobile et si on pouvait
se transmettre de l'argent via un simple
sms
alors les africains au kenya on invente
m-pesa la mobile money ou via un simple
sms on peut se transférer de l'argent
maintenant il ya des millions
d'africains qui utilise sa au kenya
orange l'a vu la développer dans 13 pays
en afrique il ya plus de 10 millions
d'africains qui utilise ça dans les pays
où orange la développer on a rajouté le
paiement de factures le transfert
international etc etc
et si demain ça arrivait en france et
que les grands-parents pour au lieu de
faire un chèque pour leurs
petits-enfants faisait un sms pourquoi
pas un autre exemple c'est les adresses
alors en afrique comme partout ailleurs
c'est le boom de lits commerce
on commande de plus en plus en ligne à
un moment donné le produit arrive chez
vous il est livré et quand le numéro 2
le numéro dans la rue ou même le nom de
la rue est assez aléatoire bien la
livraison arrive pas alors une start-up
africaine au qui a inventé la drees par
gps quand vous êtes chez vous avec votre
mobile vous déclarez votre localisation
par gps ça devient votre adresse orange
est présent dans une trentaine de pays
dans le monde dont une vingtaine en
afrique à présent le pays où orange a le
plus de clients
c'est plus la france c'est l'egypte
comment on peut faire depuis la france
pour panser des innovations qui vous
corresponde à la culture au mode de vie
des africains
c'est ça la raison d'être dit majin
louise orange c'est de partager les
idées de remonter des idées des usages
des innovations qui viennent des
continents où on habite pas forcément et
de les partager avec les équipes
d'innovation en france
alors combien ici on va faire un petit
jeu interactif pour vous réveiller là ça
fait déjà trois 3 séances que vous
écoutez combien ici connaissent
wikipedia lever la main s'il vous plaît
c'est bien donc wikipedia c'est ce qu'on
appelle dans notre jargon numérique une
plateforme de crowdsourcing
crowdsourcing c'est à dire la foule
participent à la constitution d'équipés
dia combien ici connaissent kickstarter
a pas mal aussi là que j'ai quand même
un public très avancé donc kickstarter
c'est ce qu'on appelle une plateforme de
crowdfunding les projets innovants vont
aller lever de l'argent pour
pousser un peu plus loin leurs idées
bâtir un prototype et c est bien imaging
with orange c'est au croisement entre le
crowdfunding d'innovation et le
crowdsourcing
donc on a appelé ça du crowdsourcing
d'innovation voilà c'est la partie la
plus compliquée de la présentation
comment ça marche maintenant bas chaque
trimestre on propose un thème les objets
connectés
la famille connecter la smart city donc
comme vous l'avez vu c'est un thème à
chaque fois ou qui est à la fois dans
notre quotidien et on demande aux gens
qu'est ce que le numérique pourrait
apporter dans ce quotidien
les gens viennent exprimer leurs idées
en 120 caractères ils peuvent être plus
s'ils veulent mais le minimum c'est 120
caractères et c'est le maximum pour la
synthèse de l'idée à partir de là les
gens voient les idées des uns et des
autres ils réagissent ils commentent et
ils votent sur les idées les plus
pertinentes
la communauté façonne l'innovation comme
les gens votent
il y a des gagnants les idées les plus
populaires en interagissant avec les
utilisateurs ils nous ont dit bon ok il
ya cette plateforme de partage d'idées
orange m'écoute je comprends le principe
un moment donné ces idées vont se
transformer en produit orange c'est bien
mais mettons que mon idée elle soit
populaire que je me sois pris au jeu que
j'ai envie de transformer ce rêve en un
projet entrepreneurial
qu'est ce que fera orange est ce que
vous voulez de l'argent
donc là on n'en veut pas d'argent on
voudrait de l'expertisé et du marketing
ça c'est possible donc imaginez devenu
un tremplin pour innovateurs les
porteurs d idées les plus populaires on
les invite à paris un atelier
d'innovation pour travailler le
potentiel de leurs idées et ensuite on
va les coacher sur le design de leurs
innovations
troisième chose troisième
caractéristique du majin les idées vous
voyez leurs résumés en 120 caractères
vous voyez des illustrations des
concepts au travers de photos et en fait
on s'est aperçu que environ 25% des
idées c'était des étudiants qui venaient
déposer qui sont à la fois créatif et
qu'ils ont
du temps 25% c'est des employés orange
donc on est très reconnaissant et ça
traverse toutes les couches
il n'y a pas simplement des équipes
d'innovation et puis 25% c'est des start
up qui viennent en fait exposer leurs
concepts faire un premier acte de
marketing autour de leur
commercialisation et surtout recevoir un
feedback immédiat de la communauté est
donc la troisième caractéristique c'est
qu'imaginer devenu un espace pour start
up aussi alors je voulais dit
l'innovation c'est une aventure
collective
nous on a démarré avec cette idée de
faire remonter des usages des
innovations venus d'afrique vers le
continent européen on a constitué une
équipe et on a certains qui sont ici
bertrand pierre on a eu des partenaires
charlotte kiss kiss bang bang
on les a toujours d'ailleurs et puis on
a eu un management bienveillant qui a
dit ok innover allez-y et puis le réseau
orange a fait le reste c'est à dire que
pays après pays les campagnes se sont
relayés dans les différents endroits et
après la france on est passé à la
pologne à la roumanie
bientôt à l'egypte et à l'espagne et il
ya une communauté maintenant de 5000
utilisateurs sur imagine qu'ils viennent
de 29 pays différents
on a réfléchi après trois campagnes et
on s'est dit finalement qu'est-ce qui
m'a jean apporte aux gens eh bien ça
apporte à tous les gens qui ont un
projet un domaine qui veulent
investiguer la possibilité de partager
des idées avec toute une communauté très
facilement donc imagine simplifie le
partage d'idées et on s'est dit est ce
qu on fait ça simplement pour orange
ou est-ce qu'on ouvre et comme depuis le
début imagine s'est ouvert forcément on
a répondu on ouvre et donc imagine
maintenant accueille d'autres
entreprises des start up qui veulent sur
un thème donné
recueillir toute une série d'idées pour
enrichir leurs innovations avec
imagine les oranje on a vu qu'on partait
d'une conviction la volonté de faire
remonter des usages des tendances de
pays où on habite pas une proposition de
valeur
on a cherché à faire une plateforme de
crowdsourcing différente et ça
différente elle est venue des
interactions avec les utilisateurs qui
nous ont dit est-ce que vous m'aider si
je gagne le concours
donc c'est devenu un tremplin pour
l'entrepreneur c'est ça la proposition
de valeur et puis s'est reposé sur une
équipe un collectif dont je vous ai
parlé c'est les trois points clés pour
un projet d'innovation et après le
déroulement cd interaction constante
avec les autres gens dans l'entreprise
avec le marché des itérations pour
améliorer au fur et à mesure à la
plateforme et puis ce que les américains
appellent le scanning le passage à
l'échelle pour être capable d'accueillir
beaucoup plus de monde et d'être
présents sur les différents continents
un long discours
une vidéo 21e siècle ça vaut mieux qu'un
long discours
donc je vais vous laisser avec imagine
en vidéo et je remercie beaucoup pour
votre attention
nos vies changent avec le numérique et
si vous pouviez influencé ces
changements
et si l'on écouté votre avis orange vous
invite à partager vos idées pour
qu'elles deviennent réalité chaque
trimestre imagine avec orange propose un
thème éducation shopping travail famille
santé ville intelligente
imaginez des services numériques
innovants exposer vos idées en quelques
mots et partager vos idées font alors le
tour du monde
des centaines de personnes vont les
découvrir les commenter et les enrichir
la communauté et lit les idées
pertinentes et ingénieuse cinq fois par
an orange invite à paris les porteurs d
idées les plus appréciés pour participer
à un atelier de travail avec ses équipes
innovation le résultat est présenté
ensuite sur la plate forme d'image in
avec orange une initiative locale peut
avoir une portée globale au kenya par
exemple pays où il ya peu de comptes
bancaires
la mobile money a été créé pour
permettre les virements entre
particuliers grâce à un simple sms
des millions de gens l'utilisent
aujourd'hui orange a ensuite étendu le
service du sénégal à l'egypte ajoutant
le transfert international et le
paiement de factures
l'idée traverse à présent la
méditerranée pour rejoindre la roumanie
et la france
des idées locales peuvent faire le tour
du monde et bénéficier à tous partagez
vos idées
orange vous aide à leur donner vie